c'était un géo en fait on tournait une
série ouais elle avait le badge
non
on était logé là-bas je tourne une série
là-bas attends
on est des adultes
j'ai des enfants moi aussi j'ai une
famille
est avant tout une femme à la raison
avec des termes mais vous avez Ken
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça va arrête arrête
après et non non on est resté donc on
est on tournait une série on était logé
au club on a eu j'ai l'impression que
dans 2 minutes parce que je crois que
Raymond est en train d'écrire
[Rires]
pour une série et voilà et on tournait
là-bas donc on est resté très longtemps
là-bas sur place et donc on a eu le
temps de voilà de voir le paysage
montrer les gens c'était quel style le
mec ressemble à Raymond
musclé c'est sportif
franchement il y a pas un delta de ouf
[Rires]
tu avais beaucoup plus la côte ah il y
avait des mecs moi j'avais des potes à
moi
les copains à moi
ils ont fait des trafics de match ça
veut dire qu'ils vendaient des badges
genre les vacanciers pour dire ce soir
tu mets le match commence on se vend le
badge 20 balles
ça va être beaucoup plus facile pour toi
genre il faisait des faux badges
parce qu'on avait déjà les badges qui
étaient déjà là bien sûr une balise avec
plein de matchs j'avais pas tous les
prénoms un gars qui s'appelle Gontran je
dis je sais pas
tu t'appelleras Aziz
tu t'appelles
pas compliqué comment ça
s'appelle des sports récupère ta gueule
d'accord salle de sport quel âge
attention parce que c'est magnifique et
donc il était amoureuse pendant 5
minutes
[Rires]
c'est dans les dates 1977
son mari
italien
comme on l'appelle
quand pour la pêche comme on l'appelle
en milieu de discothèque donc
est allé en voyage d'affaires il sera en
voyage d'affaires et là
il l'appelle sans faire exprès WhatsApp
il voit pas qu'il l'appelle et elle
entend genre la folie genre des meufs
qui parlent ça dans Star
et donc le gars c'est horrible mais
coupable
direct
donc là qu'est-ce qui lui a dit
je sais pas dans quelle émission
[Applaudissements]
avec plaisir
voilà
maintenant il est sur le banc des
accusés vous ferez ce que vous voudrez
maintenant si vous voulez bien entendu
lui donner une bonne leçon faut le
tromper avec son meilleur ami et c'est
son meilleur ami
[Applaudissements]
de te positionner
on a besoin de se venger
on s'est fait mal
je te jure que c'est vrai
faire de la peine aux meufs ça n'a
jamais marché
bientôt on va te parler d'un gars à
Nouméa
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est mon ami Guillaume alors où est-ce
que vous avez joué dans une case déjà
parking souterrain parking souterrain ah
ouais le gars voulait vraiment caché
[Applaudissements]
mais il y a des places
150 places restantes
là non t'inquiète pas
en faire des courses
[Rires]
18 n'existe plus
avec gyrophare
c'était une belle voiture
comment tu as senti tu t'es senti
comment
[Rires]
le cuir sur la peau ça colle et ça fait
chier
ça fait du bruit quand on
a été chez Châteaudun
juste à côté
[Rires]
[Musique]
on était un peu pressé on était amoureux
on était jeune enfin j'étais jeune
et donc voilà et donc il a trouvé un
parking
le sous-sol du parking ou un lit
excuse-moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la crème de la crème non mais sans
déconner
son dernier livre est magnifique
avec tous les présidents toutes les
intrigues de pouvoir on avait été
extrêmement intéressant pour l'instant
on parlera
pas que tu es en train de casser
l'ambiance
Delphine prépare-toi je vais te poser la
même question
commence déjà cogiter
dans un tupperware
aussi un amour de canadien David je me
rappelle le prof de ski il lui a planté
le bâton
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas de bateau
alors pour pécho un mec ou une meuf
avec qui tu sais pas parler je peux te
dire que ça c'est très dur il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait un atout physique
incroyable moi je me rappelle Castalie
[Rires]
ou pas tu vois les amoureuses étrangers
et donc toi tu étais sorti David c'est
tout ouais mais tu sais pas dans une
case non non c'était dans un club med
euh musique ah le Club Med les gars
attention
la mentalité ça reste la même quand on
se fait pécho une fois au même on s'est
péché au mille fois désolé excusez-moi
de vous dire ça mais voilà tu veux pas
que je t'envoie avec le mec je suis en
train de penser quoi
c'est pas une piscine c'est un lavoir
c'est pas possible
non mais je peux te dire tu vois non
mais ça n'a rien à voir
dans les clubs comme ça
tu es obligé un moment tu es dans un
monde à part c'est dans un monde à part
et donc et c'est vrai que quand tu
tombes sur des embrouilleurs
attention attention moi il m'est arrivé
de me faire envoyer
j'ai fermé ma gueule mais
là c'est sûr que quand on circuit fermé
tu vois toute la personne et là tu es au
tir à l'arc vas-y vas-y vas-y
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a des animations
c'est quoi les uns soit les les endroits
insolites dans une case dans une case
à l'ancienne alors j'étais au Kenya et
j'ai beaucoup de sympathisé avec un
Massaï voilà et il m'a ramené un soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
et donc il m'a parlé de de sa culture de
voilà
et donc du coup il m'a posé la question
comment ça se passe en France et tout et
au bout d'un moment j'ai compris que
voilà il me posait des questions comment
ça se passe là l'amour en France et tout
alors j'ai dit et chez vous comment ça
se passe Harry m'a dit bah chez nous on
partage les femmes donc en gros il me
faisait comprendre si j'avais envie de
venir dans son voilà j'avais à peu près
regardez c'est coordonnées
je lui ai dit non en France c'est pas
possible en France c'est un homme avec
une femme il a dit non chez nous c'est
un homme et plusieurs femmes en revanche
on a chacun un homme une vache et la
vache on ne la partagent pas les femmes
on les partage mais pas les vaches
donc le château
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je te dis ramène vite là-bas ah c'est
fou ça c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
et voilà
non après vous vouliez savoir quoi les
lieux insolites
[Rires]
sous un pont c'est pas insolite
à 15h30
[Rires]
les vignes c'est pas un solide
[Applaudissements]
je coupe un peu encore un peu de moi
il est arrivé
non mais c'est un truc de fou j'adore
quand il y a des herbes hautes partout
quand c'est pas fauché
[Applaudissements]
merci et vous mettez au milieu et du
coup personne ne vous voit il y a des
fruits alors il y a des souris qui
peuvent rentrer dans ton euh
[Applaudissements]